[Music]
hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend
what you're hearing now is i think our
third or fourth attempt
yeah to start the show i won't get into
what happened
but we just kept stumbling and bumbling
and we well first of all sona
okay not you matt okay not you but uh we
try to take where sona went down a weird
road we had to quickly stop it
yeah um then uh i had a small i'm just
gonna say it was an
aneurysm yeah um treatable treatable if
there's emergency surgery very quickly
whatever usually i swear to god we start
this show and we just
go baby and what you hear is what you
get
wait that doesn't make sense because if
you heard it you already got it start
again
no we're not starting again we're gonna
plow ahead people need to know
if nothing else we're honest so we've
never ever
had three attempts to get a top of the
show no
and today we did and i'm saying because
there are a lot of people out there that
think how does conan do it
this is incredible he must be juicing oh
my god what kind of mind is it
is can we get a cat scan or an mri can
we see what this mind looks like you
know whatever
all the stuff they did with einstein you
know can we study this what i'm saying
is that i'm trying to be open with you
and say yes
even i even i and if i can make a
mistake
it's okay that you make a lot of them
too people is that endearing me to my
crowd
what do you think i don't know i feel
like you lost it when you compared
yourself to einstein
well there are similarities oh are there
yes
yes i also uh i also have had some of my
best ideas while working in a patent
office
staring at a clock tower in a small
german town
that's what he did he just worked in a
patent office
and stared at a clock that was in the
center of town and that's how he thought
of relativity
and all those other you know that's
where he had his a-bomb idea conan he
did not have the a-bomb idea
um my point is what is happening i don't
know is that even is that even true for
whales yes that is
staring at a clock i've been there no
you haven't
yeah where's the town
switzerland baron switzerland that's
right that's right he was in barron
switzerland
einstein and he was working in a patent
office i believe at a kind of a humdrum
job
yeah and there's a little museum you can
go to now yeah and there's a clock in
the center of town
and he would stare at that clock and
that's where he started to hatch his
early
theory of relativity he was on a little
train or a trolley moving away from the
clock and that's how he got the idea he
was either moving towards it or away and
that's how you got the idea for
relativity and speed and all
you know what you know that there's
something else to this story
that's missing that if you could go back
einstein was you know loved to pretend
to be humble but you notice how he took
all the credit
i was just on the train and it was
moving and i saw the clock tower and
then i thought
and you know that there was a kid or
there was like a ticket taker who came
by and was like
you know i need to take your tickets i
need to take your tickets oh look at the
clock
everything's relative
[Laughter]
right and einstein was probably like in
trying to sleep
no but you see how the clit's going and
it's just like
do you think maybe there's a speed at
which time would slow down
and einstein was like oh [ __ ] it he's
always talking about
speed slowing down when we get faster
from the clock
i'm just something i'm well i'm just a
humble ticket taker but if any if that
idea comes of any use to you
young patent man maybe you could include
my name
what's your name my name is hasselhoffer
okay short i'll include you later
incredible einstein did this idea come
to you and you alone
fiercely did oh man cut to hesselhoffer
who by that point has lost his job at
the train station he's wandering the
streets of switzerland alone
with his broken cuckoo clock looking for
a place to get some soup
and he's reading he passes a newspaper
einstein thinks up relativity
all by himself right like an einstein
what a dick i hate him no but what i'm
saying is you know that someone else
these stories these stories
there's always something else yeah so
yes
you were there right weren't you matt
you saw the clock tower
he didn't think of that himself
definitely there was someone else the
museum is a patent office
is that fun well yeah we went up to the
door
and didn't go in why because it's like a
tiny little building and it felt
cramped i think i remember being oddly
expensive for what you're about to get
wait a minute you went to you were
standing
outside the patent office the little
office
where einstein thought up relativity and
you
all it took was for you to hand them a
piece of dark chocolate and you could
have gone and
looked at the actual room where the
single biggest idea since newton
had his theory of gravity and you didn't
go in no
well you could see in it from the
doorway sheepskate
i could see in it from the doorway what
a cheapskate you used to work at
disneyland what if i said oh yeah
when i'm on the freeway and you get
nearby you can kind of see what's going
on in there
i'd understand i didn't go by say yeah
bless you brother i understand
i've driven by oh i was we took off lax
and we banked and i could sort of see
disneyland off in the distance
yeah i got the idea you don't have to go
and and also
i just want to see the room where
clearly einstein was goofing off what
was he what do you mean goofing off
he was not doing his patent work oh sona
there's a lot of times at the office
where you sit outside my office and you
you could be thinking up a theory
equivalent to relativity or something
like that i am instead you're
watching sometimes porn at work
well in my defense first of all my
computer doesn't face anyone else so i
can watch whatever i want
and second i just think that like you
don't know what i'm doing
what's the dirtiest thing you've looked
at at work uh you really want to know do
you really want to know
okay so my uh you know every once in a
while when
especially when we go to comic-con
sometimes we think of
and learn these new sexual acts
so uh it's not that this is new but what
does that have to do with comic con what
do you mean
we're off to you know we're off to a
comic book convention so of course
that introduces the concept of sexual
acts perverse sexual acts what are you
how do those two can we all sit around
in the audience
during when you're rehearsing and we'll
be like hey does anybody know about
padlocking and then
that's how we like look into it but one
of our favorite videos and i'm saying
hour because a couple other people from
the office came and
watched it was a like a you know
maybe it was like a fisting video
oh my god did you watch that on the work
computer
i did yes oh no
i hope hr doesn't find out like anyone
cares at our office was i at work when
this was happening
yeah you were in your house in the video
[Laughter]
unwillingly i didn't know it was a prank
fisting video
i didn't know you could make a prank
show like that and i was
uh what happened to candid camera those
were such it was such innocent fun god
but uh no was i was i nearby when this
was shown because i don't look at that
i'm not gonna look at that
don't no you don't look at it but don't
you don't you never hear
people like around my office
congregating they'll be like oh my god
i thought you were watching me at
rehearsal i'm like oh my god he's quick
oh that was a good edit oh my god that
was a deep deep deep thought he just had
you think we all get around and watch
rehearsal and like cheer you on
i just yeah you're watching a maestro at
the height of his game
when you guys were shrieking and saying
that is so
amazing i can't believe that just
happened i thought you were talking
about rehearsal
not a fist going into another person's
orifice oh come on
well anyway say it like my point is to
bring it all
back is that if fisting videos had been
available
in that patent office we wouldn't have
the theory of relativity
right i think we should have gone with
take two
[Laughter]
we'll never know well many disturbing
thoughts
i was going to say a lot to chew on but
i don't want to oh
come on